didn't put it in your mouth and it pops
in your mouth oh no I'm scared
no no really it's it's so much fun I
[Music]
know what that thing is relieving for me
thingy is it like a gremlin sound like a
Furby things like pregnant nurse Gary
boy and then they grow and they they get
older and bigger and then that movie
where it was like a gremlin I know I
think it I genuinely do you think it's
the ground I didn't rig ready yeah I
said Furby what is it
I was just about to do that
got it those things that snap on your
wrist these are criteria straight good
guys yeah that's not what they're for
mooing
what is this oh it's okay it's like
silly-string goo oh oh my god good
whacks badly I saw that this is I know
that I did like that weird like gak it's
you again I have it yeah she look like a
type of like burp that you have that's
like really nice yeah
the slides on the upside down
[Music]
what is it what does it do put it in
your mouth and it pops in your mouth
oh no I'm scattered and no no really
it's it's so much fun oh oh no it's
supposed to do don't worry and I need to
leave my mouth right now
[Music]
[Music]